on today's show we're going to talk to
several people with very unique
situations
all trying to make it in the pandemic
season we're going to talk about
narcissism
and we're going to hear from a nurse
about what folks are really going
through inside the hospital system
stay tuned hey what up what up
i am john and this is the dr john
deloney show
a live show about you for
you and by you where we walk with
real people going through real
challenges and we help them make the
next
wobbly crooked step towards a brighter
future
in the darkness it is 20 20 in the
darkness that is the political mess the
rising covet cases
schools opening and closing and opening
and closing
husbands leaving wives checking out
i'm here to walk with you we are here to
walk
with you and we talk about everything on
this show all of it no matter what's
going on in your heart in your mind or
your family
there are millions of other people going
through it too
and that's why i'm here that's why i'm
here to let you know that you're not
alone right
and so we're going to talk about love
loss family issues
special needs brothers and sisters
finding love again
we may talk about two things that you
can do
right now to change the world and i was
going to say these are things that make
me crazy
right that make me nuts but
i'm going to flip it around and i'm
going to quit whining for a couple of
days
that used to be one of my core covenants
right just to stop whining just accept
what is
and move on right control what i can
control put the rest down
whining has never solved anything in the
history of the world
ever right and so instead of whining i'm
gonna flip it around and i'm gonna turn
these into action statements these are
two things you can do right now to
change the world number one
put your freaking cart back in the
grocery store
parking lot if you're in a target or a
walmart
or a publix or a kroger i don't care
where you are if you're in a hardware
store
put the cart back in the little cart
space
and i know it takes an extra 42 steps
for you
but it signals to the rest of the world
hey
this is where these things go and i'm
going to be a person
who puts things back where they go in
that little act of
kindness and collective rule following
it's not even rule following it's just
communal action right you're going to
minimize
door dings you're going to help other
people know where the carts are
just put your cart back and then the
second thing is this
wherever you go whenever you leave your
house make it a mission
to pick up just two pieces of trash they
could be tiny
if you are a go-getter that can be huge
but usually they're just going to be two
little things like a wrapper
and like a like a gum wrapper and an old
box of cigarettes or
a lid and a coke can whatever
pick up two pieces of trash if every
person did that the world would be a
little cleaner
we'd see each other picking up trash and
we'd know that guy's on my team
she's in my neighborhood we're all in
this together
so put your cart back pick up a couple
pieces of trash those are two ways you
can make the world better
and when the world starts getting better
then things then people's hearts start
lifting people's minds start lifting
and then it gets a little pinhole of
light in the dark train wreck that has
been 2020
right and let's not lie to ourselves
there's
major economic consequences there's
covid still running rampant in fact it's
it's escalating all across the country
it's not showing any signs of slowing
down politics
good god almighty dude it's just meth
and banjos out there with our politics
it's just a dark time if you pick up a
couple pieces of trash
if you put your cart back if you wave to
people at crosswalks
you're just shining a little bitty
pinhole of light in the darkness
so whatever's going on in your home in
your heart or your head i'm here to
stand with you here to walk with you
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to johndaloni.com
show that's johndalone.com show and fill
out the form
and you can just email it to us from the
website
all right let's go straight to the
phones let's go to tara in amarillo
texas yeah marilla by morning tara good
morning how are we doing
good morning thank you so much for
taking my call thank you for calling how
how's
i before we get going um i've got some
buddies in amarillo and they said the
coveted spike has been something fierce
the last few weeks you all doing okay
yeah we're doing great yes it has been
up that's for sure
good deal i'm glad to hear that so how
can i help this morning
well i have a mentally handicapped
brother who lives in a small group home
and normally he works in a workshop
situation
and so he gets out daily but during
covet that's been
very few and far between times and and
right now
they are closed again at his home
currently he can't have anyone that
comes in to visit and he can't go
out anywhere to visit um and he's gone
from calling me
because i'm 350 miles away but he's gone
from calling me almost daily
um and talking um to never calling
uh unless i initiate it and um when i
do call him he just will absolutely not
communicate at all i just listen to him
breathe
um he's struggled with depression you
know but it's just
totally shut him down now and and i just
i don't know what i can do to help him
and and that's kind of why i'm calling
you is ideas on what i can do to help
him
um during this time with his situation
wow thank you for your call
thank you for your trust there and i
appreciate you being somebody who loves
their brother
um absolutely both because of and in
spite of his challenges that he's got so
what's the nature of his
special needs well he's mentally
handicapped um
i would put him maybe you know at third
fourth grade level
as far as you know um his communication
skills and that kind of thing he
he is uh physically very good i mean he
over the years
he's 55 now so over the years he's bold
he's played tennis special olympics
he loves video games he's very good at
him he's good at
card games um you know
horseback riding he loves that kind of a
thing
he's never been a big talker but you
know he will get on a tangent
and talk and chat about you know his
bowling game and his tennis and things
like that and it's difficult now because
he has nothing to talk about that's
you know i can i can feel his pain there
you know that
he has nothing to talk about you know
does he does he have a full grasp of
what's going on
or is he you know if he's at a third
fourth fifth grade level
is he wrestling with this as most third
fourth and fifth graders are which is
suddenly their world
shifted underneath them and they get it
intellectually right they'll hear that
we're not gonna be able to go to work
today or go to school today
but that's not appeasing their hearts is
he getting it or is he just struggling
i think he struggles with that i think
he's been told and they try to you know
make it
with all of them in the house you know
to try to explain but if i were guessing
and i don't know this for positive
he feels like he's done something wrong
probably you know
yep absolutely yeah i've heard that same
conversation
across the country that folks with
special needs
and folks under the age of middle school
are internalizing what's happened over
the past year
as something they've done if they would
have just been a little nicer or kinder
or washed their hands then this wouldn't
have all happened and
um that's that's just a whole other
devastating psychological consequence of
what we've been doing here
so um he lives 350 miles away
and have you tried facetiming him have
you tried any other
technological communication other than
just the phone call
right yeah we have done face timing um
and
and it was working okay like maybe
april may-ish and now he's gotten to
where he doesn't want to do that
i'm struggling with getting him to
charge his devices
um because i'll try to call him on his
cell phone or on facetime and
it you know it's not charged and you
know i've been trying to work with the
house
people on making sure that's done but um
struggling with just getting that
communication there to him
um and and you know the last time we
faced time you know he just he just
struggled with even lifting the ipad and
you know seeing me and at me seeing him
so have you ever seen him go through a
pretty significant depressive episode
nothing like this okay are they at the
home are they getting
getting the the residents out and taking
them for walks getting them out
outside i don't think they're going for
walks they might put them in a van and
and drive them around and i've been told
that he doesn't want to even do that he
wants to sleep
sure yeah um so it's been my experience
with
adults with special needs that as much
as the rest of us
but in a very pointed and unique way
the ability to work makes
a it brings an esteem that can only be
achieved through
accomplishment and work right and being
able to go somewhere with purpose
and go somewhere and accomplish
something
is a major driver of self-efficacy
that's i'm talking like an idiot here is
a major driver of self-esteem for
adults with special needs and when that
gets taken away
that when when you take away somebody's
purpose when you take away somebody's
well-being
that's just devastating right mike rowe
of
the dirty jobs fame was here in the
ramsey building a few months ago
and he he just off-handedly dropped a
line while he was talking
and it has stuck with me he said when
covet broke out
and we determined there was essential
and non-essential workers
you know we said essential workers were
media personalities and
nurses and teachers things like that
he said inadvertently we told 300 plus
million americans you're not essential
just go home
we'll mail you a check and i had never
thought of it that way but we have just
told people across the country
eh we don't need you go on home and
we'll let you know when you can come out
and it's been devastating and i just
i my empathy for your brothers is is
heavy on my heart right now
um because for somebody who can't
understand
and is just being told stay here stay
here stay here
the the him withering underneath himself
is is to be expected right and it's and
it's heartbreaking
so a couple of things you can do number
one i would call the home
and with like all the kindness
yet forcefulness you can muster
i would strongly recommend they get
folks out to take walks
and whether that is a you can give him
some sort of
exercise program that quote unquote
becomes his job or
give him some set of goals that he can
accomplish by walking around the
neighborhood
whether that's giving him one of those
really cheap fitbits that he can count
steps what we want to do is little wins
we want to do little tiny what i would
call micro accomplishments
um micro goals for him that are gonna
both
get him a sense of purpose but also get
him outside
and get him sunshine and get him moving
around
and if he's in texas there then the
sunshine's gonna still be on him
and it'll be cool but it won't be
freezing and that would be a gift to him
both
both physiologically right the vitamin d
and the in the
fresh air and all that and if he's doing
it with the community that will help too
but it also is going to give him a sense
of purpose that he has been taken away
from him because he can't go to work
another thought would be would he be
able to play
and kind of leave man talk about twist
of fate here i'm recommending this on
on my show would he be willing to play
video games with you
yeah i think he would i if you
challenged him and kind of talked it up
like talk some trash some good brother
sister trash and just
say hey i've been thinking and i'm ready
to dominate you in some
um video game that y'all could edit so
yeah that might be a possibility
that you could get one even and i can't
i'm telling you this man i'm always
telling people to get off the screens
but this may be one of those unique
moments where getting one of those
uh microphones and you do your best
trash talking sister you can
um to get him out of his shell and give
him something to look forward to
and this would be a moment of
accountability for you if you put
something on the calendar for him a
couple of days a week and said on
tuesdays at six o'clock
prepare for big sis to crush you right
and get him
and get him fired up that way if he
would do that and engage with you there
that would be a unique way that y'all
could get connected and it may be a way
that he could get connected with your
kids if you've got them
with your spouse with other people in
the family too and again you're giving
him a sense of purpose you're giving him
something on the calendar to look
forward to
and then i think it's really important
for you to recognize this
unique moment and that total
heartbreaking powerlessness
and you are such a great sister you're
focused on how you can help him
but i also don't want you to miss this
moment where you're gonna have to look
in the mirror
and exhale a little bit and drop your
shoulders and realize
how limited your personal power
is right have you experienced that have
you gone through your own grief on this
deal
yeah i think so i think it's gotten more
and more here at
you know with things going up and them
closing again and the hope of them
reopening
you know they're telling us january and
i'm like you know that's a long haul
yeah it really is it's and it's a long
dark hall right it's
it's the winter months are not good to
be pegged in and locked in
is there a way he could come visit you
or is that a no-no
yeah they won't allow it see he was
going to my parents house
every wednesday and playing games and
eating dinner and
they have not allowed that since like
february
wow wow yeah it looks like you're gonna
have to do the limited things you can
to lean in here and again i i would love
some sort of fitness
regimen and
the best i've been able to read and i've
tried to keep up with the science of
what's going on as much as possible
getting outside and going for walks is
not only
not going to contribute but it's going
to help folks particularly the vitamin d
side and the good breath side and number
two
yeah if you can plug in and play some
video games there but i don't want you
to miss the opportunity to get in touch
with yourself
because this just sucks and i want you
to spend a couple of minutes
mourning what you can control and what
you can't
i want you to spend a few moments on the
regular talking to somebody that you
care about and just
being able to express
i hate this i hate this
and this isn't whining this isn't
complaining this is just acknowledging
so many of us are just running into
solving mode solving mode and
man we just have to pause for a minute
and just own
it's no good man i hate this so tara i
think for the call
i wish i could give you more concrete
like hey just do this and this and this
and i'm guessing here right
i'm guessing here my hope is that you
can
use your the love and care you've got
for this young man
um and get him plugged into some video
games i think that'd be a lot of fun
and man whenever i think i can't get
weirder james here i am on the show
recommending people play video games but
um tara thank you so much for that call
um let's go
let's go to actually let's do this i've
got a
quick little thing i want to talk
through here i
get more calls not more i get a lot of
calls
about narcissist narcissist narcissist
narcissist
everyone's always talking about a
narcissist and so
it's one of those terms that's thrown
around a lot these days
everybody's talking about it they're
saying their dad's a narcissist their
brother's a narcissist
so i want to go through a quick
deconstruction reconstruction of what a
narcissist
actually is what it what it what it's
not
and i'm gonna point you to what i think
is
the best reference i've seen so far and
it is not a science journal it's
actually written by
a by by an author a fiction author
um but here's a couple of thoughts so um
here's what a narcissist is it's
somebody who
who technically has been diagnosed with
narcissistic personality disorder
and it's a personality disorder
characterized by an inflated sense of
self-importance
a need for admiration but most
importantly
a total lack of empathy and a sense of
entitlement
for a true narcissist other people exist
for one purpose and that is for them to
be
self-fulfilled they believe that
everything around them
happens for them and that people are
merely tools
they are merely um puzzle pieces
for their own use right
narcissist rarely seek help right
they expect everyone around them to meet
their needs
they ignore the impact of that their
negative comments
have on other people they ignore the
fact that they hurt other people
because they don't care they don't have
that empathetic ability
and this is this is not a
a jerk right we'll talk about that in a
second here this is somebody who
legitimately lacks the ability to be
empathetic
they can be loud and brash super
confident they can be charming and the
charm seeks to
get other people to fulfill their needs
but they can also be shy
and hypersensitive thin skin very
fragile
and they can take control in what terry
reel calls the one down position
they can be underneath you and quiet and
make it all about them
the person that just sits in the corner
and everyone goes hey what's wrong with
them
why are they acting like that and then
when they're when their needs aren't met
they get angry they throw temper
tantrums
they have attitudes of i can do all of
these things and when you say hey i had
a good success their first response is
oh yeah well one time i
right that's a narcissist someone who's
unable to acknowledge other people
but there's also jerks and one of the
greatest
greatest articles i've read
is it's written back in 2014
it's at lisatomsononlive.com we'll put a
a click to
um we'll click to it in the show notes
the name of the article
is it's again it's not a science article
it's not a journal article
it's just called narcissist or a-hole
know the difference
right it's written by a fiction author
and i think she does a great job here
she writes the narcissist is incapable
of intimacy
remorse or deep feeling loving a
narcissist is like pouring
all of your affection into a funnel and
just watching it
fall out the bottom right they use
manipulation and psychological control
to get what they want from people they
live in a world of denial
but here's the thing jerks are like that
too
sort of right an a-hole will often
be described as rough on the outside but
they're mushy on the inside
they are capable of intimacy even though
they've got a tough exterior right
they are capable of caring for another
not
every action is motivated by self-gain
often people are jerks
often people lash out often people try
to get what they want
and they're not narcissists they're just
covering up for some deep wounds that
they've had for years and years and
years
there is some similarities but at the
end of the day
here's a here's a way to know if
somebody's a narcissist or not
here's a way to know if you're a
narcissist or not
if you want to change if you really wish
that your family would love you if your
dad
yells and screams wants everything his
way
but he also deeply loves you
if he doesn't know how to say i love you
so he buys you something he doesn't know
how to say i love you
and he doesn't have money to buy you
something so he tries to fix something
if he wants you to get straight a's and
he's always pushing you and pushing you
you could have got a 95
but he's doing it because he wants you
to have a better life than he has which
is different than
he just wants to be able to tell people
work that his son's really smart
is that his daughter's really fancy
right
narcissists can't be different if you
think
man i'm tired of hurting people then
you're not a narcissist
if your dad loves you he's not a
narcissist he may just be a jerk
right if you think you're in a
relationship with a narcissist if you
work for one or have a parent who's one
be watchful pay attention to how they
treat you
and others it's your responsibility to
set
boundaries remember that no is a
complete sentence
focus on what you can control and what
you can't control
and then this is the big one you gotta
kill the fantasy
if someone is a true narcissist and let
me be clear they're rare
they're very rare people who can't feel
empathy
very rare right there are way more jerks
there are way more idiots than there are
narcissists
you got to kill a fantasy they're going
to continue to drain you and
use you like you are a screwdriver or a
hammer
for their own good you got to kill the
fantasy set up boundaries and you got to
move along
if somebody though is tough on the
outside they're a complete jerk
they're a complete idiot
but they do have empathy they do love
you then that's where your boundaries
end a carefully guided
direct but loving conversation about hey
this hurts
hey i want to connect with you but when
you talk to me like this when you treat
me like this it hurts
that's where those kind of conversations
can be really helpful so check out lisa
thompson on live.com again we'll click
to it
we'll link to it in the show notes um
it's a great
great quick easy read narcissist or
a-hole know the difference it's really
good
if you have more questions about
narcissists give me a shout give me a
holler
or if you think someone that you love is
a narcissist let me know and we can talk
through it
all right let's go to lisa in orlando
florida lisa good morning how are we
doing
good morning dr john thank you for
taking my call thank you so much for
calling how can i help this morning
um so my family um
and my in-laws have been
homeschooling since with each other
we've partnered up
since march now so since this pandemic
started
and i just want to know how we can
create healthy boundaries and
because recently the the relationship
has changed
a bit and we're coming up into some
challenges that might change the
arrangement we have
talked to me through those talk about
those
so um this is my sister-in-law um
so my husband's sister uh we've been in
a close relationship we've been close
for a while
um she's married and recently they
um had one of their episodes um fights
uh that caused us to kind of lose that
trust in sending our kids over there for
school
did they have the fight when your kids
were there no
no no um we heard about they told us
they told us what happened
and the details and everything and we're
just not comfortable
with um everybody being at home working
from home and whatnot to send our kids
over there for
her to teach them there so
what happened in that fight that made
you lose trust in someone that you
love and care for um they've had similar
fights in the past and this was kind of
the last straw
um and there was you know a
door slamming a glass breaking
it caught if i felt like it kind of got
violent to the point where i just
i i don't i've heard too many
of those stories coming from them um
yeah so now you feel like your kids
aren't safe there
correct okay and so how can i help what
are you thinking about doing
well um we recently um we
we changed up the arrangement to where
you know
we expressed our concerns and said um
let's just have school here four days a
week now rather than sending them over
there
uh two days out of the week so you you
are now taking all the teaching on
no she um my sister-in-law comes over to
teach on the days that she was supposed
to teach at her house
but she's expressing that
it's hard to face us because we're
disappointed and
and we uh don't trust them anymore and
that's what the emotions that she's
having to face
being in a home along with people who no
longer
trust her well yeah so it feels
so let me see if i can get this right um
because i'm almost
in a in a rare turn of events golly man
on this show i have recommended someone
play video games and now i'm siding with
the person you're calling about
so she had a fight with her husband
and they were throwing glasses at each
other and yelling each other and acting
like
five-year-olds right to the point that
you said i don't want my kids over there
anymore
i don't trust her i don't trust her
husband i don't trust that environment
and so but you wanted to still have her
teaching your kids
and so her quote unquote punishment was
she's got to come teach your kids at
your house now right
and and we also recently
hired someone to come teach on her days
so that she doesn't have to teach at our
house anymore and she's not happy about
that
okay so she said i don't like being
because the way you drew that up is very
much like you're her mom
and now she's grounded too yeah to your
your line of sight right and she's an
adult she's allowed to yell and
be an idiot with her husband all she
wants and
you're an adult and you're good for you
said i don't want my kids in that crap
right i don't want my kids around that
environment so
that's awesome but then you you punished
her
then she decided she didn't like the
punishment so she's back to being a
grown-up so she's off
and you hired a tutor essentially to
teach your kids in your home is that
right
right okay and so she doesn't like that
does she
does she want things to go back to the
way they were
yeah she does she wants us to send our
kids over
to at her house and you know
for for consistency and normalcy again
and i'm
me and my husband are just not
comfortable with that yeah she didn't
get a vote
i mean if she set up an environment
where you don't feel your kids are safe
then
tough luck you know what i mean and i
know that's hard and i'm proud of you
for drawing a boundary
um boundaries often come with
you know challenging challenging
derivatives right the
your relationship's never going to be
the same but
i think the the the the fracture in the
relationship started when she had yet
another temper tantrum with her husband
right right so when you tell her
hey i hired a teacher we don't need you
anymore you take care of your kids i'll
take care of mine
how'd that conversation go well it's
more so
you know we still want the kids to be
together but
instead of her teaching it's on those
two days that she's responsible for
it's the tutor that teaches to
you know we wanted her to kind of focus
on herself and maybe that's overstepping
boundaries but it's
um you know she did express that you
know it's it's hard for her
to come here having to deal with that
and it's overwhelming
and you know we wanted to give her some
space and some time to
to process all of it so the tutor is
essentially to take over
her um be flexible enough to where if
she needs it she could
uh take those two days off and then you
know
if my husband needs it he can take those
two days off because he's also teaching
the kids as well
oh well now i'm back to your side then
you guys are being overly generous here
so five minutes ago when i said i wasn't
on your side
i'm an idiot i i'm super on your side um
it sounds like what y'all have done
sorry sorry no it sounds like you guys
are being overly generous
by saying hey we're going to teach your
kids too
we're going to pay for a tutor you take
the time that you need
and it sounds like she's having a pity
party
and she's embarrassed that she
set up a home environment that you don't
want your kids there anymore
so the grown-up thing for her to do is
to come say i'm sorry i'm going to work
on myself
and i'm going to work on getting better
that's not going to happen right
and the childish thing if she continues
the childish behavior is she's going to
put
make you feel uncomfortable for drawing
boundaries in your own home
and i'm just going to i want to empower
you don't
right if you've got the money and the
ability to pay for a tutor
then that's going to be better for
everybody her kids are welcome that's
super generous of you and that even
gives your husband a break when he needs
it good for you
yeah honestly i wouldn't lose sleep over
it if she wants to come back and circle
up and connect the friendship great
and you don't have to rub her nose in it
doesn't sound like you are right
if y'all still be friends when y'all can
get together for dinner so be it
but if she suddenly feels uncomfortable
i get her feeling uncomfortable but it's
her own choosing
if she doesn't just i don't feel
comfortable i feel sad
well that's her deal right and i
i think you're right you can't make her
go work on herself i would even suggest
offering quote unquote space for her to
go work on herself is a little bit
presumptuous
right she's going to be who she's going
to be but i do think it's noble that you
have set up a scenario where
a you drew boundaries b you're going to
continue the
the the agreement you guys had
and so you're helping educate her kids
and you're giving her some time off
for herself um that's noble good for you
hopefully she will circle back
hopefully she will come and say hey i'm
really sorry
i screwed up here and me and my husband
going to work on this
i don't think that's going to happen
unfortunately but
it'd be cool if it did and until then
just love her
just take the responsibilities and
continue to draw your boundaries for you
and your family
high five to you that's awesome and good
for you guys for being
in a financial position where you could
even do that
um all right so i wanna instead of
taking a third call today
i want to circle back to a call i
received
as a follow-up to a trauma
conversation so a few weeks ago
maybe a month or two ago i took a call
from an er doctor
and he was asking me the best way for
him to
circle up after him and his team in the
hospital had experienced trauma
and one of the main suggestions i gave
him was to make sure he
separated people by role by power
hierarchy
right get the janitors together get the
doctors together get the nurses together
get the admin staff together and the
main reason i recommend this
is because it just takes one person
in a one-up position it just takes the
doctor walking in and going
hey everybody last night was a hard deal
that's what we signed up for here that's
how the hospital runs if you need
something go talk to somebody
and let's get back to it and then
suddenly you've got an
entire team of people from the custodial
staff
to the to the the charge nurses to the
the anesthesiologist who are dying
inside
but they suddenly don't have permission
to talk they suddenly have to be silent
and sit on their trauma
and that stuff's cumulative and it
weighs and it weighs and it weighs on
you
and i got a great call from um from
someone who circled back and said hey
this hasn't been my experience
and so i want you to listen here and
we'll follow up to the call
uh let's let's listen to the call i was
just listening to your podcast on my way
to work this morning
um where you're talking to an er
physician about deep breathing and you
suggested breaking up into groups nurses
with nurses doctors and doctors
custodians of custodians and i just want
to say as a ten year nurse
i have to say the best debriefs have
been when the whole team
everyone that has been even a small part
of
a story where a child is killed or
something like that when we're all
together
and going through that the death of a
child is a great equalizer we're all
human
in those moments and sometimes it's
helpful to hear
what the doctor saw in that moment and
how
maybe there was no chance that this baby
was gonna make it
from his perspective and i don't know i
don't think about work performance
reviews when i'm in those moments and i
just wanted to share my two cents on
that because
that has been one of the most healing
parts of working in the job where it's
almost impossible to be there sometimes
i number one love the fact that
she called in to give me her heart and
her two cents i welcome
everybody if you hear something that you
just love on this show please call me
let me know
if you hear something on the show that
you disagree with and you think hey that
hadn't been my experience please
call and let me know i'm learning too
so i want to 1 000 affirm what she said
she said she loves her er situation
because she's got doctors who will
debrief with her whole team
who have set up an environment where she
doesn't think about performance review
she doesn't think about looking weak
where she's got head er doctors who will
come in and say
i understand that everybody's hurting
here last night we lost a child
that child had this challenge and this
challenge in this physical trauma
and everybody did the best they could
that kind of leadership
is a gift and if you're a leader out
there if you have people who work for
you
if you have hearts and minds and souls
that you are responsible for
and i don't care what level if you're a
head
phone screener and you've got 30
like phone screeners below you or if
you're an er
doctor and you've got hundreds of people
on the floor that look up to you as the
as the head honcho
remember that by including people
letting people have
their own feelings letting people hurt
out loud
that's such a gift you're preserving
hearts you're preserving marriages
you're preserving parents
you're preserving years of trauma
and if you as the leader are struggling
with
feeling hurt if you as the leader in an
er situation
can't acknowledge we lost a kid last
night and that
sucks if you can't do that you need to
go see somebody
you need to go talk to somebody if
you're a fireman
and you cannot you're a fire chief and
you can't
rally up your firemen and you can't
rally up the people who
support you guys and the ems staff and
say hey what we just saw was
hard it was really tough and it's gonna
hurt
everybody in different ways please come
see me if you need something
please go see the aftercare if you need
somebody
be that kind of leader so i want to a
thousand percent affirm this situation
the most ideal thing we can do is
everybody get in a room i loved what she
said we're all human
and the loss of a child is a great
equalizer the loss of a loved one is a
great equalizer
nobody escapes that kind of pain i hope
you're that kind of leader
but unfortunately most aren't most folks
in hierarchical organizations which is
all of us
we have to temper our feelings we have
to temper our trauma we have to temper
our concerns and hurts
by what our boss thinks and if our boss
says just move on get over it
then unfortunately we all got to move on
and get over it
and so boss is out there this is your
time to shine
this is the we're in the holiday season
after an ugly
2020 with no sign of it letting up into
2021
it's your time to sit down with your
team and say
i'm here for you guys and this sucks
how are you feeling how are you doing
are you taking care of yourself i want
you to get out of here on fridays for
the next few weeks
i want you to start coming in at 10
o'clock in the morning so you can be
with your kids in the morning before
they go to school
or i want you to come in at 10 o'clock
so you can have an hour to run around
the front yard before your kid starts
zoom school whatever it is
be a boss who understands that people
work for him with wives and husbands and
dreams and hurts
and debt and challenges and fears be
that kind of leader
be the kind of leader that she'll call
in and say no no i never even thought of
hierarchy when we were hurting
what a great shout out to your bosses
thank you so much for that call
and one more thing before i go i want to
read an email that i just got from tyler
it's a little bit long
but i want you to stay with me on this
it's from tyler in durham north carolina
he writes my name is tyler weber and i'm
an icu nurse from
durham north carolina and i'm doing this
as a shout out by the way guys i'm doing
this as a shout out to the nurses who
are continuing
to go in day after day after day after
day with a coveted situation
with all the other health issues that
are going on
so here's what tyler writes i just
discovered your podcast and the first
one i listened to after scrolling
through the titles was
first responders in trauma online dating
woes and compromise in marriage
the firefighter you spoke with in that
podcast might as well have spoken for us
nurses as well
in five years i've probably seen close
to a hundred people die if not more
i'd say a quarter of those deaths have
been in the last six months due to covet
some of these deaths are easier to deal
with as a nurse than others some are
downright horrific
what a lot of people don't realize or
think about is where do they take those
burn victims or
multiple vehicle accident victims they
bring them to us
where many of them live or die based on
what we do with our minds and our hands
we get to know them and if we're not
careful we form relationships with their
families for days
weeks or months after what brought them
in it's heavy and it only gets heavier
as time rolls on whether you acknowledge
it or not
as nurses it's our eyes and hands and
minds and voice that care for you
we assess treat communicate and make
recommendations to the physicians
we bathe you we suction your airway we
intervene immediately in critical
moments we are your advocate
we do for you and your body what your
body and you can no longer do for
yourself
we bear the greatest brunt of your awful
situation outside of you and your family
and in the covet icu's we can't even
allow family to come
we are the only human interaction you
have and we might be the last
that's heavy every time
when the end is near nurses hold your
hand and stay with you so you don't die
alone
when the end is near we pull the
breathing tube we cut the life support
medications off and start the comfort
medications
when it's been decided in collaboration
with doctors and families and nurses
that your time has come
despite our greatest efforts it's our
eyes
our ears and our voice that are there
for you as you
ease your way from this wrecked body to
glory
the doctors come after we call them to
pronounce time of death
our hands are the last hands you hold
while you're clinging to life
our words are the last words you hear
and the last words are typically spoken
to us
we are at your bedside around the clock
and not only that my dad has brain
cancer my wife and i brought our first
baby into the world in march
and i was recently accepted to nurse
anesthesia school after a grueling
application process
it's been a year even without covit and
this is we have all
we all have different stresses like that
in our lives and then nurses
we go to work and we go to work and we
go to work
and then we do it again and we do it
again
tyler i want to tell you we love you i'm
grateful for you
and the service of every single nurse
across the country
the nurses who are in it every day then
they come home
and they're dealing with the regular
nonsense of life outside
if you know a nurse if you're listening
to this and you've got nurses in your
family
you've got nurses in your neighborhood
it's time for us to circle back
and say thank you and not say thank you
by ordering a pizza or sending flowers
it's time to say thank you by calling
somebody on the phone and saying
you've had nine months of absolute hell
how can we help
you have been in it and in it and in it
what can i do for you and it's time we
get out our mowers and start mowing
lawns and get out of rakes and start
raking
it's time that we do the best we can and
take kids for walks
get them out of the house
we can try to lift folks arms up in the
desert we can try to
let nurses know that we love them
to every single person out there
continuing to go to war
every day in these makeshift tents and
these makeshift
you know mobile morgues nurses
thank you thank you for loving us more
than you love yourselves
so as we wrap up the show i want to
circle back to
a song i've loved since middle school
and if she's out there she knows why
it's from the self-titled album
of one of the worst band names ever
bad english in 1989
they came up with this that's one of the
greatest songs ever written
it's called when i see you smile and
here's what they say
sometimes i wonder how i'd ever make it
through
through this world without having you i
just wouldn't have a clue
because sometimes it seems like this
world's closing in on me
and there's no way of breaking free and
then i see you reach for me
and sometimes i want to give up i want
to give in i want to quit the fight
and then i see you and everything's all
right
when i see you smile i can face the
world oh
you know i can do anything when i see
you smile
i see a ray of light i see it shining
right through the rain
when i see you smile everybody this has
been the dr john deloney show